Saudi Arabia,
mother of
people, God forbid, fool, God grant safety and well-being.
Muslim countries
aid non-Muslims. The Muslim establishes the...
don't tell me Algeria does with a company
in China, and a Chinese company is working with Russia.
Russia is working with Z and Z. Algeria petrol to the
Italians, it to Israel.
They have to be invested.
In one, in one,
in one,
the problem is
God Almighty.
Where is Omar?
God Almighty is the
age of the
elders.
And if God commands
leaders, and
if
take back
unity,
back
[music]
to
[applause].
The sch
now about the, you are monks, donkeys. The in the... is for every
time
you.
Commander of the Faithful, trustworthy of the criminals. The madmen, criminals, madmen.
God grant safety and well-being.
The ruling was revealed by God. Imam
Abdul Wahab,
Imam Abdul Wahab,
Abdul Wahab. Glory be to
God.
The agreement of Muhammad Ibrahim. The policy of God. Glory be to God. By God, the ruling was revealed. My brother, the Sharia, the Sharia. Abdullah Muhammad, peace be upon him. The Sharia,
Abdullah, by lineage of the hypocrite. The
Sharia, the Sharia of the Chosen One, peace be upon him.
God curses you.  And I seek refuge in God from the Islam of
God Almighty. I seek refuge in God.
You are worse. God is angry.
[Music]
Yeah
The people,
that's why you know if you see me defending Saudi Arabia, I do, but
I know there is a plan to destroy it,
and you can see how they do it when they want to use arguments. Look at the offices. There is a party.
People of one,
so make your mind. The devil is the
Messenger of God. The
creed of the devil. The Messenger of God. The
loan of the devil. The grandfather of Najd is
forbidden. God is
following your honor for the sake of Western citizenship. Then in
Saudi Arabia,
yes, you know, you are Algerian. He
sells. Normally, he sells. He sells his honor. He sells his religion.
Passport. It is known. It is known,
my dear. It is known.
These people tell you about Saudi Arabia, and he is selling his
honor, his father and mother, for the sake of a British passport. A
family he throws away. His religion. No, that's why I
know why they don't like me. Because I expose the hypocrites.
Yes, if you say in His blessings, if you say in
mistakes, in virtues, yes,
but don't lie. You tell me this and that, and you are
following honor, your religion and your honor for the sake of citizenship.
Praise be to God. I mean,
praise be to God.  My brother, we saw him, thank God. We saw him for a week. They were... I
mean, we were walking... but you can
ask two questions, there's something wrong with
that, my brother. Look, by God, everyone who lies to me, whether they're a
Rafidi or a liberal, thank God,
or a Sufi, this is
nonsense, by God. This is an example of that. Once, an
Algerian called me on TikTok and said to me, "You
go to Saudi Arabia? I saw it live, I saw it. No, this is in private. This is in private. You were this." He said to me, "You're Saudi, they give you money." I said to him, "What now? I didn't go to Saudi Arabia,
and I was defending it because I'm defending the Aqila of
Islam." When I went, in the video, they said that when I
went, the state and the people honored me with gifts. I say this, I have no problem with it
because they are my family.
My dear, peace be upon you, may God bless you. I
have no problem with it. I say the truth. They honored me, but does the
Saudi call? They said, "Sun, say, by God, I'll
never say 'Sun.'"
But when they saw me, by God, excuse me, when they
saw me, I stood with them as a man in the West, defending
them because they are my brothers and my family, and I'm defending my country and the
children of Muslims. What did they do?  When I went
to them, they honored me, and I
said on the video, and I thanked the prince. I
have nothing to fear, but I challenge any lying scoundrel to
come and say that Al-Shamsi said disbelief or
faith or this and that, or any country. But
if someone from Somalia called me, they would say, "
Shamsi, take me into the fold of Islam without conditions." I would take him without any problem.
But you came and said, "The situation is forbidden." I seek refuge in
God from that.
This person is the same one who mentioned someone
named Maar, an Algerian. What is his name? He praises
this person. I told him, "You are one of the sons of the Harkis,
because only a Harki would praise this person.
This person is destroying the Algerian army, may God protect our
country, Algeria, may God protect it." So he insulted me. I am defending my country.
Some people say, "You are in Britain, what does that
mean?" So I am in Britain, selling my country? If you are a Harki and the
Harkis are in your blood, then it's something else. You come to
Britain and sell your mother, your father, your country. I will not sell
my country in Britain, in France, in a cave above a
cave. I will not sell my country. Praise be to God, as he said, "My country, even if it is unjust to me, is
dear to me, and my family, even if they think ill of me, are honorable."
My country has wronged me. I'm leaving
my country, but my heart aches for it. I won't go back. I'll
speak out about it publicly and mention its tragedies so that I can
see the United Nations bring its files to bear. I
understand, it's all about
money. I told him, "How come? Look at
the university in the video, how is it?"
No, thank God. I swear, look, brother, I performed
Hajj, and I saw the party members there. Some are
subservient to Amin, they weaken in Saudi Arabia, they take money.
I'm Saudi, they give us money, we're open,
thank God. My brothers, you take water from
Britain, Sheikh, you take money from an
infidel country. They take money, houses, everything, you have no problem.
Algeria helps, you tell me, we help them
in glory. Come,
thank God,
because the difference between me and them is that I consider these
countries Muslim, my family and my blood, but these take
money from Britain, and it's infidel and oppressive. Glory be to God, there is a vast difference
between the hypocrites, the children of Satan, who have
strayed from the Sunnah of the Prophet, the Most Merciful. And praise be to God, Lord of the
Worlds.
This is for my brother, they don't like me. Why? I don't
know how to hit.
We know them, we know
them. This one tells you, he tells you, he says, "
Those countries, oh, it's normal." He
tells them, "I'm Jewish." He tells them, "I'm
with the Children of Israel." There's no problem with that. For the sake of the
British tribute and the promise of Algeria to France, he defends
Algeria. Yes, he
said something inappropriate. He said, "We'll
send you back to your country." He went out with his son and said, "
I love France." He added, "
Oh, he added." You saw nothing but
skin.
God forbid! I mean, brother, it's self-interest. Yes, may God guide him. But the point here is, brother,
he might say, "I'm only looking out for my own interests." But okay, and if
you're the leader of sedition, a
leader of sedition, afraid for your position, God
forbid, you sell out. Yes, there are some rulers—I don't defend them, I don't know their names—but I don't defend them. But some rulers, you see good in their countries, you see religion is strong there, you see, God willing, they help religion and everything. They are not infallible. May God bless you. I understand, my dear brother. So, praise be to God. Brother, you
must know how to expose the hypocrisy of these people.
Sheikh Saleh, this sheikh said, "The strongest response to
the opponents is to expose their contradictions in the fundamentals."
Yes, by
God, you... Yes, we are jealous for Algeria.
Regarding Saudi Arabia, we don't accept what is forbidden. We do
n't accept what is forbidden anywhere, but there's a
Salafi way and a Kharijite way. We follow the
Salafi way and we pray to God Almighty
to guide them.
If I can advise, I will.
But these Kharijites...
[music] May
God bless
you. Praise be to God, the
Kharijites are among you.